[Musik]
auch die guten morgen und herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einem neuen
fonds auch bei den kanal meine damen und
herren alle juden der muslime aufgebaut
und ihm wie allerdings schaue mich jetzt
eine schöne folge zum wachwerden und
danach fahren wir heute zum christen
roma weiterhin luca ich will seinen top
hits a video machen der völker dabei ich
hab mir gedacht ist
na klar komme ich warum ich werde auch
noch was gutes aufnehmen ich weiß noch
nicht genau was denn gestimmt titeln
aber bisher noch gar kein plan
allerdings konnten wir erstmals user
immer nach dem zähneputzen auch ihre
fans verein helfen was sich lassen
halt's maul bevor wir allerdings jetzt
gleich rockfan werden machen wir uns
erstmal drei freunde schaut euch mal die
tollen eier an die ist super geile in
der pfanne kommt ja okay eigentlich so
habe ich die hier gemacht wird
hallo leute ich bin zum ersten mal hier
die haben wir im kino gebaut ist besser
als alle kölner kinos was ist das denn
das ist ja super seinem ausstieg
gerettet hatte
ihr habt dem aus gerettet es ist also
meine damen und herren ich habe gerade
erfahren dass wir kein top 5 pizza hier
machen werden sondern frittieren
wir zitieren pizza ist aktuell es ist ja
voll der food trends in amerika ist so
zitierte pfizer show mittlerweile ganz
normal dass es ist klein ich weiß auch
nicht was die leute sich dabei der junge
das ist hoffe ich habe das damals bei
joko und klaas und dass man gezielt
wohnwagen war wieso alles mögliche tore
das war richtig das war auch schon auf
jeden fall kommen drops video nicht
heute sondern morgen aber da werde ich
euch dann noch mal den link die
beschreibungen oder abonniert den fall
jetzt hier drauf da steht es doch von da
und chris bosh
lassen abo da erhält sie mal daran
gedacht so eine pommesbude aufzumachen
in der kölner schon vollauf überlegt wir
sind gerade dabei etwas zu zitieren ist
es einfach nicht pizza hawaii das
arbeite ich hätte nicht gedacht auf den
ersten blick ok auch sehr wohl aber
folgende ob es schmecken wird erfahrt
ihr morgen
wir haben gerade eine halbe stunde lang
verschiedene pizzen frittiert freunde
einmal ist es bald so ein bisschen
mulmig nix kostet also freunde schaute
ich auf jeden fall morgen ist wieder
anders wird es fakt aber wir werden
jetzt noch für diesen blog hier eine
kleine challenge drehen uns war
schauen wir was ich hier in der küche
alles an zutaten mit findet seine er
wäre bayer werk in ketchup keine ahnung
war und damit einerseits sich ein rezept
überlegen seine pizza und auch ich als
wären wir nicht genug bezeugt schon
jetzt sechs stücke gegessen aber
nochmals zwei also quasi eine kleine
pizza challenge mit allen zutaten die
wir hier in der küche finden das heißt
jetzt haben wir beide erstmal jeweils
fünf minuten zeit um uns ein rezept zu
überlegen
[Musik]
mit
das heißt dass unversteuerte um
schnecken wir das mal probiert schnack
schnuck einstein aber okay okay oder wer
es nicht nach nordsee ist nicht gut voll
ist nicht okay aber wie mein hund sein
tier perfekt ich kriege das bild
bekommen genau das nicht gekauft
früchte so viel grauen schleck ein paar
sekunden später
jetzt verstehe ich auch wieso das bundes
wechseln
das wissen können es war so haben sich
zwischen den zähnen okay was wollen wir
haben witzelte wäre die tat einräumte
jetzt haben hoffentlich jeder fünf
minuten zeit und auch ein rezept
überlegen uns beide jetzt angeschaut was
das bezahlen in der künftige job schon
eine vorahnung was ich machen werde aber
wir sehen uns dann gleich wieder wenn
wir unsere konzepte vorstellen
leute wir haben uns gerade eine menge
gedanken gemacht was wir auch unsere
jeweiligen stücke drauf packen wir haben
hier schon zwei stücke pizza margherita
vorbereitet auf denen noch nicht draußen
trocken außer tomatensoße und käse ich
würde sagen robin ist der gast darf
anfangen und ist ein hitze
rezeptvorschlag er okay also ich dachte
mir weil wir gerade in dieser prämie
challenge herausgefunden haben dass
schokolade doch ganz geile ist dass ich
mich an etwas gewagtes traue ich sehe es
schon auf dem zettel so halten gericht
gedroht der boden kommen erstmal eine
karamellsoße jetzt ist die frage wieso
karamell weil ich weiß dass bananen und
karamell immer gut harmoniert das
harmoniert mit schokolade erich wirth
löffel körpervolumen banane amerika
melder auch für mich gar nicht alt er
war wie gut es aussieht und fertig
also freunde roxette ist hier so ein
bisschen süße mit karamellsoße
schokosoße bei mir habe ich daran
gedacht dass wir weil ich habe es das
hier gesehen und ich dachte mir ich mag
in rudeln ich mag pizza pasta ich werde
jetzt mal eine wenig von diesen nudeln
kochen die wirklich darauf meine pizza
drauf packen und dann was passt zu
nudeln habe ich mir gedacht jetzt müssen
wir mal ein rezept zusammenflicken ich
habe mir gesagt freundin würde ein wenig
so rucola passende und leichten jahr
audi noch voll um jeden fall da habe ich
gedacht es sonst hat man es nicht allzu
häufig auf der pizza sondern mit der
vegan und ein bisschen chili ich habe
mir gedacht salz und pfeffer ein
bisschen drauf montag habe ich hier bei
dir in der schublade gesehen hier vorne
ich habe ich ein wenig mittwoch es gebe
ich habe hier habe ich nämlich kräuter
croutons entdeckte ich weiß nicht ob
müssen merken wie die westlichen
notenbanken und die nudeln und rucola
hast schinken oder freunde ich hoffe
erstmal die nudeln und dann die seit ich
mein meisterstück also leute wie nudeln
sind jetzt fertig das heißt ich streue
die man hier einfach alle auf die pizza
darauf die wird noch hart am dampfen
das ist das seien sie noch so viele
sieht man wie viel hinwil wo sie stücke
weil wir haben uns auf jeden fall noch
gedacht wir sind ich habe mir gedacht
das könnte ein wenig zu trocken sein
deswegen haben wir noch einen kräuter
knoblauch knobloch nice das wird auch
noch schön hier drüber jazzfreunde aber
freundlich werde den rucola nicht
nachher auftraten sondern ich will das
alles so im ofen schieben und wird
trotzdem anschauen geschmeckt als ich
nehme
hätten zuletzt auch ein wenig die
salzburger und dann jetzt noch eine
klinische und dann diesen schinken so
offen also ich glaube gar nicht tragen
oder dass die hälfte runter wir warten
bis alles fertig ist dann sehen wir uns
wieder drei sätzen späte reue wir haben
eine gewisse zeit gewartet und man siehe
da die pizzen sind fertig die heftigkeit
aus der schweiz ist nicht meine die auf
müllkippen und meine damen und herren
das ist mein prachtexemplar mit nudeln
rucola salz pfeffer und technologie von
dem gewissen herrn knusprigen rob mit
erdbeeren bananen karamellsoße
schokosoße aber jetzt probieren wir das
ganze mal auf jeden heißt viel zu heiß
ich finde richtig wild gab keinen scheiß
ich finde meinen richtig scheiße ich
würde sagen die tauschen wird ja doch
mal meine ich bin mal das stück hier
legal eine speck vorbei ich bin deine
aber auch nicht so schlecht
die hat was interessant ist aber in
deutschland ist nicht übrig den
offiziellen christopher ward ich bin
echt überrascht
kritische gesichter
natürlich freut es hat auf jeden fall
mehr spaß machen würde ein paket
freust du dich über ein paket
wir sind wieder zu hause angekommen
freunde mit ist tatsächlich gab ja wir
waren bei rob und jetzt ist mir auch ein
bisschen schlecht regens meine sehr
verehrten freunde wollte ich euch eine
kleine sache fragen die gewählt hat ein
wenig oberflächlich ist allerdings mein
team das immer zu mir und zwar weit jude
das mir schwarze shirts besser stehen
als weiße shirts ich bin euch mal ein
weißes schwarzes foto von mir ein also
ein foto mit einem weißen schatten
einfach mit einem schwarzen shirt und
ihr könnt dann über eine umfrage
funktion jetzt hier abstimmen also macht
das jetzt mal
[Musik]
ich mag mich einfach auf so wie ich ganz
normal bin ich habe gerade schon ein
bisschen den block geschnitten den er
gerade sehen allerdings geht es für jude
und nicht nur auf danke ich halt alleine
ins gym bist doch mitbekommen
an der stelle wird den heutigen blog
jetzt allerdings auch band meine damen
und herren das training war echt sehr
sehr sehr sehr krass anstrengend licher
gerade und auch geduscht hat eine
kleinigkeit gegessen und ich freue mich
gerade einfach mega krass auf mein bett
deswegen freunde wenn es euch gefallen
hat dass ich heute mittwoch mal diese
challenge gemacht habe dieses pizza
backen wie gesagt loks video kommen
morgen auf seinem kanal dann das gern
mal ein leichter bei diesem blog ihr
freude
morgen kommt kein video aufnahmen kann
als ich glaube ihr wissen es langsam an
jedem zweiten tag kommt ein video weil
ich jeden zweiten tag blogger ist ja
alles auch egal freude ich jetzt
schlafen und das solltet ihr auch tun wo
ich das kann nicht gespielt es für euch
ist schlafen ist immer gut
[Musik]